[Musique]
en France ces 10 dernières années 596
000 hectares de terre et de forêts ont
été artificialisés
alors ça vous évoque peut-être rien mais
en fait c'est l'équivalent de la surface
d'un département français rasé de la
carte comme ça pour être remplacé par du
béton
et ça ça continue on estime que d'ici 5
ans c'est l'équivalent du département du
Val-d'Oise ou de la Martinique qui
risque d'être
ensevelie ou du béton
ce constat moi je l'ai fait il y a très
peu de temps il y a un an
avant ça j'étais déjà engagé pour
l'écologie
je me suis engagée assez jeune
j'organisais des marches des grèves pour
le climat des actions coup de poing
quand j'ai commencé j'avais 16 ans
et j'ai commencé à m'engager parce que
j'ai lu des rapports scientifiques
alarmant exactement à faire le lien avec
là où j'habite
moi j'habite dans les Pays de la Loire
et mes grands-parents habitent sur une
île c'est l'île de Noirmoutier
et donc sur cette île et bah au fur et à
mesure des années on se rend compte que
certaines plages ne sont plus
accessibles à cause de la montée des
eaux à cause de l'érosion
et pire d'ici 80 ans cette île risque
d'être submergé par la montée des eaux
et moi ça me paraissait insupportable de
me dire que les paysages dans lesquels
j'ai grandi dans lequel j'ai eu beaucoup
de bonheur ben puisse être détruit et
que les générations futures ne puissent
pas les voir
et c'est ça les comptes c'était c'est la
peur des conséquences du réchauffement
climatique
c'est se lever chaque matin en entendant
des nouvelles toujours plus
catastrophiques et quand même de voir se
lever et quand même de voir vivre dans
ce monde qui ne semble pas écouter les
alertes
et donc c'est pour ça que je me suis
mobilisé c'est pour ça que nous nous
sommes mobilisés alors on a envahi les
rues on a manifesté on a alerté on a
essayé de sensibiliser comme on pouvait
au changement climatique à la crise
écologique en cours
et ça a eu du succès quand même parce
que on a réussi à instaurer l'écologie
dans le débat public on a réussi à faire
de l'écologie un sujet majeur
mais derrière il y a eu peu de
retentissement politique il y a eu peu
d'actes concrets de vrais changements
politiques
et donc c'est le retour de l'éco UCT
parce que on se dit bon on a peur donc
on agit mais en fait on finit par avoir
encore plus peur parce qu'on voit que
rien ne change et que c'est pire
et puis un jour
j'ai été contacté avec mon groupe
d'activistes pour aider parce que il y
avait besoin d'aide pour sauver des
jardins à côté de Paris
donc on y est allé sans trop savoir où
on mettait les pieds
et là ça a été un vrai déclic
imaginez moi j'habite sur un boulevard
tout gris à Paris il faisait chaud
c'était la canicule je rentre dans le
métro le métro était bondé je sors du
métro au porte de Paris et j'arrive dans
un jardin un jardin magnifique luxuriant
avec des arbres fruitiers partout de la
verdure ça débordait c'était magnifique
il faisait frais c'était incroyable
ça c'est les jardins d'Aubervilliers les
jardins ouvriers d'Aubervilliers c'est
des jardins centenaires qui sont
répartis en plusieurs dizaines de
parcelles qui sont attribuées à des
ouvriers et à des habitants du quartier
c'est un endroit qui est fabuleux il y a
des centaines d'arbres fruitiers il y a
des centaines d'espèces protégées il y a
des hérissons des lapins des oiseaux des
hirondelles il y a aussi des enfants qui
jouent qui font de la balançoire pendant
que leurs parents font plantes de
légumes
c'est un lieu qui est très vivant il y a
une biodiversité unique en Europe
et pourtant moi j'étais là parce que il
fallait les sauver ces jardins
avec l'arrivée des Jeux olympiques de
Paris en 2024 il y a de nombreuses
aménagements qui sont prévus dont la
construction d'un centre de confort pour
les athlètes avec un solarium avec un
spa avec un restaurant et il est prévu
de construire cet espace de confort sur
les jardins
et quand on voit légèrement on se dit
mais comment c'est possible comment
est-ce qu'on peut oser détruire un
endroit pareil
alors du coup on a continué on a re on
s'est remobilisés mais à la différence
des autres fois où je m'étais mobilisée
et engagé c'est que là c'était très
concret on savait que si là on faisait
rien tout ça là tous ces jardins ils
allaient être détruits c'était très
concret moi quand je me suis engagée je
me suis engagée parce que j'étais triste
pour les ours polaires qui meurent sur
la banquise et c'est très louable et je
pense que beaucoup de gens se sont
engagés en voyant ces images terribles
de des ours qui meurent sur la banquise
parce qu'elles font
mais à la réflexion j'ai jamais vu
d'ours polaire et je pense pas en voir
dans ma vie
alors que pourtant ben les hérissons les
oiseaux les abeilles qui sont à 1 km de
chez moi et qui sont tout aussi menacés
je finissais par les voir tous les jours
et c'est là où ça devient très concret
alors on a fait des pétitions on a
manifesté on a interpellé les projets
les personnes qui qui gérait le projet
et on a même fini par occuper le terrain
on a campé et on s'est relayé jour et
nuit pour retarder l'arrivée des
chantiers
et ce combat il avait il avait un sens
il avait un sciences déjà scientifique
parce que le béton en magazine la
chaleur alors que la végétation elle
permet la fraîcheur et puis aussi parce
que nous vivons aujourd'hui la sixième
extinction de masse de la biodiversité
pour rappel la cinquième extinction de
masse c'était lors de la disparition des
dinosaures
alors c'est peut-être pas la meilleure
idée du monde que d'aller bétonner un
espace vert dans un département qui ont
comporte peu et détruire la biodiversité
autour alors que on subit de plus en
plus de canicule de sécheresse et que
éclab biodiversité disparaît petit à
petit
et puis il y avait un deuxième sens
un sens tout aussi important un sens
beaucoup plus humain
et beaucoup plus personnel
je vous disais quand je me suis engagée
et je me sens engagée par peur parce que
j'avais de l'écho anxiété et là de
s'engager dans ce projet là où on est
dans les jardins on voit on voit
concrètement les arbres les animaux on
les voit concrètement et on se dit
je peux agir pour ça j'ai un pouvoir
pour agir pour ça si je ne fais rien
tout ça peut disparaître et j'ai le
pouvoir peut-être de changer les choses
et ça ça donne beaucoup de sens et ça
permet aussi de
diminuer un peu son écho anxiété et ça
permet enfin voilà regarder ce qui se
passe autour de nous observer le vivant
bah c'est de venir vivant à son tour et
finalement prendre soin des jardins
c'est aussi prendre soin de son jardin
intérieur
et donc
après ce constat et après ce malgré ce
combat
ça n'a pas suffi
un jour les engins de santé sont arrivés
un jour les CRS ont délogé les
activistes
et on a regardé les larmes aux yeux
c'est le jardin se faire détruire
on a vu les pelleteuses arracher les
arbres fruitiers on a vu les rouleaux
compresseurs écrasés les hérissons on a
assisté à tout ça impuissant en se
disant que c'était quand même assez fou
qu'on puisse détruire ce que la nature
avait créé en centaines d'années en
quelques minutes
et puis c'était pas tout parce que
ensuite le chantier devait évoluer
et l'idée c'était de bétonner le plus
vite possible
pourquoi parce que le collectif qui se
battait sur les jardins avait lancé un
recours juridique
parce que on n'était pas très sûr que
détruire des espèces protégées c'était
très légal
et donc la mairie vous laisse dépêcher
de bétonner comme ça on avait plus de
soucis tout était détruit
finalement la justice nous a donné
raison
la destruction des jardins et des
espèces protégées étaient illégales
et c'est là où c'est très injuste parce
qu'on se dit que tout ça ça n'aurait pas
dû avoir lieu
il restait plus que de la terre
mais c'est aussi je pense une force
parce que cette terre ça faisait des
centaines d'années qu'elle était là
qu'elle a été enrichie de plus en plus
par tous les végétaux tous les animaux
tous les humains aussi qui ont
cultivaient qui ont vécu sur ces sur ces
terres et cette terre aujourd'hui elle
est encore très riche et on peut encore
faire pousser des choses dessus donc
aujourd'hui le chantier est arrêté
et les habitants et les jardiniers sont
en pleine réflexion pour savoir quoi
faire de ce jardin comment la réaménager
et comment le rendre encore plus joli
pourquoi je vous raconte tout ça
je vous raconte tout ça parce que des
endroits comme ça des endroits comme les
jardins d'Aubervilliers des terres des
forêts il y en a énormément en France
beaucoup vraiment beaucoup
il y en a 350
et c'est des exemples très concrets
je parle par exemple des terres les plus
fertiles d'Europe à Saclay en
Île-de-France qui sont menacés par la
création d'une nouvelle ligne de métro
je parle aussi du deuxième fleuve de
Corse qui est menacé par la création
d'une entreprise de traitement de
déchets ménagers et d'amiante
je parle aussi de vigne en Gironde qui
sont menacés par l'extension d'un
aéroport pour les jets privés
et je parle aussi de garrigue à côté de
Montpellier qui sont menacés par la
création d'une autoroute
ces exemples ils sont très concrets et
je vais pas vous faire toute la liste
mais en fait il y en a partout il y en a
partout près de chez vous près de chez
nous il y en a partout dans chaque ville
dans chaque départ de chaque région
et ces projets ils sont ils sont
pharaoniques et ils sont complètement
insensés
mais à chaque fois qu'un projet de ce
type a lieu sa naissance s'accompagne
toujours de collectif de mobilisation
il y a des habitants des activistes des
agriculteurs des jeunes des moins jeunes
ces gens-là qui n'ont pas forcément de
lien entre eux à la base mais qui se
rejoignent pour défendre et pour sauver
du vivant à côté de chez eux pour sauver
là où ils vivent finalement
et je trouve que c'est très beau de voir
que les gens se rejoignent et se battent
pour pour sauver oui là où ils habitent
et en plus ça fonctionne
ça fonctionne comme on l'a vu à
Aubervilliers s'il y avait pas eu de
mobilisation citoyenne les jardins
aujourd'hui ils existeraient même plus
il y aurait même plus terre et il y
aurait un superbe solarium à la place
pareil il y aurait en ce moment il y a
des terres fertiles à côté de Nantes
elles auraient été détruites pour
construire un nouvel aéroport
pareil en Guyane un bout de la forêt
tropicale qui serait aujourd'hui polliée
pollué au cyanure pour pour récolter de
l'or
et donc tout ça ça marche ça marche et
on voit bien que bon ces projets ils se
multiplient ils se multiplient
mais en fait nous les gens on se
mobilise pour dire stop
et c'est ça que je vous inviter à faire
aujourd'hui
invité à regarder autour de chez vous ce
qui se passe parce qu'il y a sûrement
des terres qui sont menacées
et Victor Hugo disait d'ailleurs que
c'est très triste de voir que la nature
parle mais que le genre humain n'écoute
pas
et c'est ça que je vous propose c'est
d'écouter d'écouter la nature d'écouter
les termes menacés à côté de chez vous
et vous indignez
créer des pétitions manifester
interpeller bloquer
occupé tous ces moyens sont bons pour
agir à côté de chez nous pour sauver le
vivant à côté de chez nous
est-ce que vous pouvez faire aussi c'est
qu'il y a plein de collectifs des
collectifs il y en a énormément à chaque
fois qu'il y a des endroits menacés
comme je l'ai dit à chaque fois et des
collectifs qui se greffent au projet
on peut rejoindre ses collectifs et
l'idée c'est de pas laisser une seule
goutte de béton sur le vivant qu'il nous
reste
et donc si vous vous souciez des
canicules que vos enfants vont subir si
vous vous souciez du fait que les
paysages de votre enfant risque de
disparaître je vous invite à trouver à
développer à sauvegarder votre propre
jardin
[Applaudissements]